[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und einen
schönen guten Abend das Wichtigste vom
Sport von rudizana hallo schönen guten
Abend und es gibt eine Nachricht aus
Berlin die für besonders viel
Aufmerksamkeit sorgt
gigantisches Hilfsprogramm gegen hohe
Gaspreise mit einem Rettungsschirm von
bis zu 200 Milliarden Euro hilft die
Bundesregierung Verbrauchern unter
Wirtschaft die umstrittene gasumlage
wird gestoppt
den Inflation steigt dramatisch auf 10%
im September fachleute warnen vor einem
dauerhaften Wohlstandsverlust
Hurricane Ian verwüstet Florida Meter
hohe Flutwellen hinterlassen enorme
Schäden Millionen Menschen sind ohne
Strom
[Musik]
nur wenige Tage bevor sie erhoben werden
sollte ist die gasumlage jetzt also vom
Tisch stattdessen will die
Bundesregierung bis zu 200 Milliarden
Euro in die Hand nehmen um unter anderem
eine Preisbremse für Gas und Strom zu
finanzieren so sollen Bürgerinnen und
die Wirtschaft entlastet werden wir
sprechen gleich mit unserem kurspenden
darüber wo das Geld herkommen soll
zuerst aber Christiane hübscher mit den
Details
Finanz und Wirtschaftsminister können
wieder lächeln nach stundenlangen
Gesprächen zu dritt ist die Einigung da
und der Kanzler heute erstmals negativ
getestet verkündet das Rettungspaket
noch zugeschaltet aus der Isolation man
kann sagen dass es hier ein Doppelpunkt
es soll dazu beitragen dass jetzt
schnell zügig und für alle schnell
feststellbar die Preise sinken für
Energie so dass sich niemand Sorgen
machen muss wenn er an den Herbst und
den Winter denkt wenn er an Weihnachten
denkt und dann das nächste Jahr und dann
die Rechnung die Koalition spannt einen
wirtschaftlichen Abwehrschirm auf ein
Stabilisierungsfonds bis zu 200
Milliarden Euro schwer daraus gezahlt
werden soll die geplante
strompreisbremse eine gaspreisbremse
direkte Hilfen für Gasanbieter und
andere betroffene Unternehmen und die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf Gas soll auch
für Fernwärme gelten dieser Abwehrschirm
ist umfassend und wirksam er ist
zugleich aber gezielt auf diese kr er
ist ein Schutz vor Existenzverlust aber
er soll selbst nicht die Inflation
befeuern Lindner hat durchgesetzt dass
die Schuldenbremse trotz der
sonderkredite ab dem kommenden Jahr
wieder eingehalten werden soll habecks
gasumlage geht die strompreisbremse
kommt und zwar so ein basisverbrauch
wird vom Staat bezuschusst für alles
darüber hinaus müssen Verbraucher den
aktuellen Marktpreis Zahlen ähnlich soll
der gaspreisdeckel Funktionieren der
spar-anreiz ist dabei gewollt die
Speicher sind voll aber wir sehen auch
dass die Verb Bräuche gerade im privaten
Bereich noch nicht in dem Maße
runtergehen wie es eigentlich notwendig
wäre deswegen bei aller Bereitschaft des
viel Geld in die Hand zu nehmen und die
Preise abzufedern die Notwendigkeit
Energie einzusparen bleibt unvermindert
bestehen das Geld soll bis Ende 2024
reichen und unbürokratisch vergeben
werden die Opposition hat danach mehr
Fragen als Antworten
mal 200 Milliarden Euro überrascht uns
einigermaßen weil wir auch in den
Beschlüssen der Bundesregierung nicht
nachvollziehen können auf welcher
Kalkulationsgrundlage eigentlich diese
Zahl ermittelt worden ist macht das ist
wirklich eine absolute Trickserei
dreistellige Milliardenbeträge an
Schulen aufzunehmen die man anders nennt
um so zu tun als würde man die
Schuldenbremse einhalten Milliarden
gegen Putins energiekrieg doch viele
Details bleiben heute im Kanzleramt noch
offen
fragen wir nach bei Theo Koll in Berlin
Theo 200 Milliarden wie soll das also
jetzt genau finanziert werden also
anders als bei der gasumlage bei der ja
nur die Gasverbraucher zahlen sollten
zahlt jetzt der Staat also im Prinzip
jeder Steuerzahler übrigens auch die
künftigen denn wir reden hier von einer
massiven Schuldenaufnahme von bis zu 200
Milliarden Euro und damit die
Schuldenbremse davon nicht betroffen
wird wird ein Schattenhaushalt aus
corona-zeiten der sogenannte Wirtschaft
stabilisierungsform wiederbelebt und mit
geliehenem Geld gefüllt also das
billigere Gas wird mit neuen Schulden
bezahlt das Geld soll locker gemacht
werden was heißt denn das jetzt dann für
uns alle als gastkunde und Gaskunden
also für diejenigen die Gas verbrauchen
ist das gleiche eine doppelte
Erleichterung erstens entfällt ja für
Sie die gasumlage die eigentlich am
Samstag schon in Kraft treten sollte und
zweitens wird für Gas eine
Preisobergrenze festgelegt und den Rest
zahlt dann der Staat bis zum Marktpreis
ungleich ist dabei allerdings noch für
wie viel vom jeweiligen Gasverbrauch der
günstigere Preis gelten soll im
ampelbeschluss ist da nur vom
sogenannten Basis verbraucht die Rede
die Antwort soll jetzt bis Mitte Oktober
eine Expertenkommission vorbereiten und
auch wie hoch der gedeckelte Preis denn
sein soll für sich selbst hat die Ampel
damit nebenbei auch erst einmal den
politischen Preis gedeckelt wobei die
Rechnung natürlich kommt und die ist
hoch und heißt Verschuldung danke für
diese Erläuterung Theke
im heute journal um 21.45 sehen Sie
einen ausführliches Interview mit dem
Bundeskanzler welche Auswirkungen der
ausgehandelte Kompromiss hat auf die
Schuldenbremse und die Ampelkoalition
ein Analyse dazu lesen Sie in der ZDF
heute App
die starke stiegenen Preise für Energie
das Ende von tangrabatt und neun
euro-ticket heizen auch die Inflation
weiter an glatte 10%, ist die vorläufige
Zahl für September ein Wert sehr weit
entfernt von Inflation in den
vergangenen Jahren zwischen 20 15 und
2020 lag sie zwischen 0,5 und
1,8%. erst im Corona Jahr 2021
kletterten die Preise wie Sie sehen
können um 3,1 Prozent und in diesem
August waren es schon 7,9 und jetzt
aktuell liegt die Teuerung bei 10%. über
Auswirkungen und Folgen Cornelia
schiemens
Rezession Inflation Wohlstandsverlust im
Friseursalon von Jana Kettner im
sächsischen Döbeln werden diese
abstrakten Begriffe plötzlich ganz
greifbar die Kunden lassen sich mehr
Zeit zwischen den Friseurbesuchen ihre
eigenen Kosten dagegen für Strom Gas-
man kann nicht planen man kann nicht
kalkulieren man kann nicht rechnen es
funktioniert alles nicht
Katja Ohlen jetzt sagt zahlt heute für
ihre Kurzhaarfrisur knapp 40 Euro viel
Geld 40 Euro hätte in einer halben
Stunde weg
im Einkaufskorb ist auch nicht so viel
drin die Inflation in Deutschland betrug
im September 10 Prozent auf den Straßen
von Döbeln spürt man die Angst was diese
Zahl für viele bedeutet
wie als Großfamilie wir können uns gar
nicht mehr leisten in dem Sinne wir
können schon gar nicht mehr sparen und
es wird nicht besser die Leute sparen
geben weniger Geld aus diese Konsum
Zurückhaltung wiederum bringt
Unternehmen in Schwierigkeiten für 2022
rechnen Wirtschaftsexperten wegen des
besseren ersten Halbjahres noch mit
einem kleinen Wachstum von 1,4 Prozent
für 2023 sagen sie einen Rückgang der
Wirtschaftsleistung um 0,4 Prozent
voraus Rezession
der anhaltende Einkommensverlust den wir
erwarten die Gaspreise werden nicht auf
das ursprüngliche Niveau zurückkehren
dass wir vor der Krise gesehen haben
bedeutet ein Wohlstandsverlust für die
Deutschen für die deutsche Bevölkerung
den die Wirtschaftspolitik nicht
ausgleichen kann
erst 2024 soll es eine wirtschaftliche
Erholung geben
also bereits zehn Prozent Inflation
Frank Bethmann an der Frankfurter Börse
was kann uns da noch drohen ja wenn man
sich so unter Ökonomen umhört ist das
Ende der Fahnenstange wo noch nicht
erreicht das hängt Stichwort rasant
steigende Energiepreise vor allem davon
ab wie kalt der Winter wird und wie sehr
es uns gelingt einzusparen insgesamt
waren die Bundesnetzagentur heute ja
gerade noch mal reichen die Bemühungen
bislang nicht aus kurzfristig rechnen
die meisten Fachleute doch damit das
Inflationsraten von über 12 Prozent in
den kommenden Wintermonaten nicht
ausgeschlossen sind denn auch jenseits
der teuren Energie steigen die
Verbraucherpreise immer schneller längst
noch nicht alle Betriebe haben ihre
höheren Kosten an die Endkunden
weitergereicht da kommt also noch was
die Europäische Zentralbank wird die
Leitzinsen weiter erhöhen und versuchen
die Teuerung damit zu bekämpfen doch
kurzfristig bringe das wenig fürchtet
US-Ökonomen Larry Summers da das Bild
eines alten Hotels bemüht indem man beim
Duschen an den Wasser hind aber die
Temperatur leider erst mit Verzögerung
reagiere Dankeschön Frank Bethmann für
diese Einschätzung
hinter den Schäden an den
ostsee-pipelions Nord Stream 1 und 2
wird Sabotage vermutet die NATO äußerte
sich tief besorgt und drohte eine
vereinte und entschlossene Antwort auf
jeglichen vorsätzlichen Angriff auf die
kritische Infrastruktur von Verbündeten
an Schweden meldete inzwischen ein
viertes Gasleck und der Betreiber von
nordstream 2 teilte auf zdf-
nach den russischen scheinreferenten in
der Ukraine kommt aus Moskau diese
Meldung der Kreml will morgen die
Annexion der besetzten Gebiete offiziell
machen
international wird der Schritt nicht
anerkannt die separatisten-chefs der
vier Gebiete hier ein Foto bei ihrer
Ankunft in Moskau wollen die sogenannten
beitrittsabkommen unterzeichnen
unterdessen fliehen weiterhin zahlreiche
Menschen aus dem betroffenen Regionen
bevor diese zu Russland gehören sollen
und auch aus Russland fliehen Menschen
immer mehr Männer im Wehrpflichtigen
Alter verweigern sich Putins Krieg
die Schlangen an den Landgrenzen sind
kilometerlang 100.000 Russen sind seit
der Ankündigung der Teilmobilmachung in
die Nachbarländer geflüchtet rund 98.000
einreisen meldet Kasachstan
43.000 Finnland und nach Georgien
reisten 53.000 aus über die Situation an
den Grenzen jetzt Christian sem
sie kommen zu Fuß mit dem Fahrrad oder
Auto über die georgische Grenze sogar
mit dem Roller egal wie hauptsache weg
aus Russland ein Exodus Russin und
Russen auf der Flucht
wir wollten keine Zeit mehr verlieren
wegen der Information oder
Desinformation dass die Grenze zu macht
wir haben das Auto stehen lassen und
haben uns auf den Weg gemacht
wir sind nicht einverstanden mit der
eingeschlagenen Politik in unserem Land
und wollten nicht in einen Krieg
reingezogen werden mit dem wir nicht
einverstanden sind wir wollen keine
Opfer und wollen auch selbst nicht Opfer
dieses Krieges werden
rund 10.000 Russen kommen jetzt jeden
Tag über den Grenzpunkt in Werni Lars
vor allem junge und die die sich die
Flucht überhaupt leisten können die
meisten gehen erstmal nach Tiflis in die
Hauptstadt einen Plan wie es weitergeht
hat fast niemand der geflüchteten
ich weiß es nicht ich habe das erste Mal
seit drei Tagen geschlafen da ist es
schwer für mich sich über Perspektiven
Gedanken zu machen
wir werden Georgien erkunden und
vielleicht weiterziehen in andere Länder
mal sehen wie sich das Leben entwickelt
georgien hat seit dem russischen
Einmarsch 2008 ein sehr angespanntes
Verhältnis zum Nachbarn und so gibt es
schon Proteste dass die georgische
Regierung die Russen einfach so ins Land
lässt
wir wissen nicht wer sie sind vielleicht
sind es russische Agenten oder
russisches Militär für Russen wird es
jetzt jeden Tag schwieriger die Heimat
zu verlassen Finnland zum Beispiel will
Russen mit touristenwieser nicht mehr
einreisen lassen regionale Behörden
behindern Russen zunehmend an der
Ausreise und das russische Militär hat
ein berufungspunkte an den Außengrenzen
eingerichtet in Russland steigt die
Angst das Putin die Grenzen bald ganz
dicht macht
die Kriegsverbrechen in der Ukraine
verschiedene Organisationen versuchen
Sie möglichst umfassend zu dokumentieren
eine der AktivistInnen Alexandra
matwickuk wird dafür jetzt mit dem
alternativen Nobelpreis ausgezeichnet
seit mehr als einem Jahrzehnt kämpft sie
für die Stärkung der Zivilgesellschaft
und Demokratie in der Ukraine mit dem
right lively Hood Award werden Personen
geehrt die sich für Menschenrechte
Umwelt und Frieden einsetzen
weitere Preisträgerinnen und Preisträger
kommen aus Somalia Uganda und Venezuela
wie viele Menschen riskieren wenn Sie
sich für Demokratie einsetzen zeigt sich
auch in Simbabwe da ist heute ein Urteil
gefallen gegen die Autoren und
Filmemacherin zieht sie dann garemember
die nur 2021 auch mit dem Friedenspreis
des Deutschen Buchhandels ausgezeichnet
wurde
dankaremba wurde für schuldig beschunden
für Funden wegen Aufwiegelung zur Gewalt
sie hat an einer Demonstration für mehr
Demokratie teilgenommen über den Fall
Sandra Theis
es klingt harmlos am Nachmittag
verurteilte ein Gericht in Harare zieht
sie dankaremga nur zu einer Geldstrafe
doch dahinter steckt der Versuch sie zum
Schweigen zu bringen denn sollte sie
sich in den kommenden fünf Jahren erneut
schuldig machen drohen direkt sechs
Monate Gefängnis das Verfahren seien
Angriff auf ihre Rechte sagt dankaremga
der Staat macht sein Ding wir sind die
Bürger und als solche haben wir Rechte
die versucht man uns zu nehmen hier in
Simbach
Rückblick im Juli 2020 unterstützt die
Schriftstellerin und Filmemacherin eine
Protestaktion die die Regierung verboten
hatte sie fordert Reformen und die
Freilassung von Journalisten und wird
festgenommen
als Emerson manangarqua 2018 auf
langzeitdiktator Robert Mugabe folgte
war die Hoffnung groß dass sich etwas
änderten Simbabwe doch das Land steckt
tief in der Krise die Wirtschaft liegt
am Boden die Inflation ist riesig die
Arbeitslosigkeit auch und wer es wagt
die Regierung zu kritisieren muss mit
Strafe rechnen
was uns auffällt ist dass sie generell
das Justizsystem benutzt wird um die die
den Mund aufmachen zum Schweigen zu
bringen und zu verfolgen
so anscheinend auch im Fall von
zizi-dangaremga Meinungsfreiheit sieht
anders aus
vorhin über Inflation und Rezession
berichtet keine guten Voraussetzungen
für einen Börsengang aber porsche hat es
heute trotzdem gewagt es war einer der
größten Börsengänge der deutschen
Wirtschaftsgeschichte Sven Klaas
euphorische ausgelassene Stimmung das
sieht man selten in diesen Tagen auf dem
Frankfurter Börsenparkett
ein historischer Moment für Porsche ein
großer ein stolzer Tag bisher gehörte
der Autobauer aus Stuttgart Zuffenhausen
komplett der Volkswagen AG die erlöst
durch den porsche-börsengang nun 9,4
Milliarden Euro Kapital dass man in
Wolfsburg gut gebrauchen kann die
benötigt man eben für die Transformation
in Hinblick auf die Elektromobilität im
Hinblick auf die Digitalisierung auf die
Nachhaltigkeit auch wenn die Porsche
Aktie heute keine Zugewinne verzeichnet
für die Zukunft sehen nicht nur die
Porsche Verantwortlichen selbst viel
Potenzial man weiß das natürlich
genügend reiche Leute weltweit unterwegs
sind die auch schwieriger Zeit immer
wieder sich an Porsche leisten können
denke ich mir wird das längerfristig auf
jeden Fall eine Erfolgsstory werden der
Unternehmenswert an der Börse schon
jetzt höher als der von anderen
Oberklasse Herstellern wie Daimler und
BMW
wir befürchtet hat Hurrikan Ian den
US-Bundesstaat Florida schwer getroffen
mit historischen Auswirkungen sagt der
Gouverneur von Kuba aus kommt hatte
ihren die Küste Floridas mit extremen
Windstärken erreicht sie sollen zu den
stärksten je in den USA gemessenen
gehören besonders in Fort Myers hat es
die Menschen schwer erwischt doch vom
ganzen Küstenstreifen werden
Zerstörungen gemeldet Claudia Betz
der Sturm Riss alles mit sich Dächer
Häuser hielten den Windgeschwindigkeiten
von 240 Kilometern pro Stunde nicht
stand Lebensgefahr für alle die in ihren
Häusern geblieben waren und Verzweiflung
darüber dass alles verloren ist
die harte Arbeit hat sich nicht gelohnt
alles ist zerstört und wir müssen
komplett von vorn anfangen und wo soll
man überhaupt anfangen
die Sturmflut war Meter hoch Hurricane
Ian peitschte das Meerwasser in die
Küstenorte Autos werden weggeschwemmt
und einige mutige helfen den
unvorsichtigen für 14 Millionen Menschen
besteht eine flutwarnung zahllose Häuser
stehen unter Wasser sind unbewohnbar
ganze Wohnviertel sind komplett
überflutet und Millionen sind ohne Strom
die Schäden haben ein historisches
Ausmaß und wir stehen mit unserer
Bewertung ja erst am Anfang ich glaube
wir haben noch nie eine Überflutung
solchen Ausmaßes gesehen und auch keine
Sturmflut dieser Größenordnung
jetzt hat eine riesige Hilfsaktion
begonnen Nationalgarde und
Katastrophenschützer bringen die
Menschen aus ihren überfluteten Häusern
Jetskis und Boote schwärmen aus um Leute
in Sicherheit zu bringen
kaputte Stromleitungen sollen schnell
repariert werden zehntausende Monteure
sind dafür unterwegs der Wiederaufbau
wird Jahre dauern
kommen wir jetzt zum Sport Deutschlands
Volleyballerinnen hatten heute ja keinen
guten Tag bei der wm-modi nicht wirklich
nach zwei Siegen jetzt die Enttäuschung
im dritten Gruppenspiel der Volleyball
Weltmeisterschaft in den Niederlanden
und Polen musste die deutsche Mannschaft
ihre erste Niederlage hinnehmen das Team
von Bundestrainer vital Heinen unterlag
Titelverteidiger Serbien glatt in drei
Sätzen
mit Lina alsmeier steht das rot
gekleidete deutsche Team zunächst im
ersten Satz gut da die
universalspielerin blockt erfolgreich
und macht Punkte wie den zur 1715
Führung
die Weltmeisterinnen aus Serbien sind im
polnischen Lodge aber nur kurz irritiert
mit Routine blocken sie sich zum 25 23
Satz Erfolg
der belgische Bundestrainer vital Heinen
sieht dennoch den vielleicht besten Satz
seines Teams bei dieser WM den zweiten
Durchgang gewinnt Serbien 25 zu 22 bevor
die Jana Boskovic den entscheidenden
dritten Satz wieder mit 25 23 für ihr
Team sichert zweimal gewonnen einmal
verloren die deutsche Auswahl kann die
zweite Runde aber noch erreichen
nächster Gegner Olympiasieger USA am
Freitag
wird auch nicht leichter zum Auftakt des
achten spieltages der Fußball-Bundesliga
kommt ist morgen zum Duell Zweierteams
die bislang enttäuschten Leverkusen zu
Gast bei den Münchner Bayern die ihr
tief zuletzt auch in der Nationalelf
nicht abschütteln konnten
Selbstvertrauen haben die kriselnden
Bayern Gewissen nicht getankt in den
sieglosen Tagen unter Bundestrainer
fliegt aber auch Leverkusen hat noch
gehörig zu knabbern an viel zu vielen
Gegentoren nach nur einem Siegen sieben
Spielen ist der Respekt vor dem Bayern
ungebrochen obwohl die sich mit dem Tore
schießen zuletzt schwertaten hier etwa
beim 0:1 in Augsburg
sie hatten genügend Torchancen manchmal
ist der Spielverlauf auch entscheidend
das könnte ein Glück oder auch die
Effektivität vor dem Tor der Bayern
Trainer sieht ganz genauso wir müssen
nicht alles umkrempeln das ist glaube
ich auch ein Punkt aus der Analyse wir
haben glaube 93 Torschüsse sind letzten
vier Spielen gehabt die Chancen einfach
besser nutzen dann dürfte die bayernwelt
wieder in Ordnung sein
das war es schon kurzer knackiger Sport
007 zum ersten zum zweiten und zum
dritten bei Christie's in London hat ein
biete ein echtes James Bond Auto
ersteigert diesen ersten für ungerechnet
3,3 Millionen Euro Kratzer vom letzten
filmeinsatz inklusive eine
vorfahrtgarantie ebenfalls und auch
andere Exponate kam natürlich nicht
wörtlich unter den Hammer etwa ein
faberget ein Modell aus dem Klassiker
oktopussy alles für wohltätige Zwecke
denn Merkel Bond ist immer im Einsatz
für das Gute
morgen wird es freundlich oft scheint
die Sonne das Wochenende dagegen bringt
Wind und Regen genaues gleich von Katja
horneffer Christian Sievers begrüßt sie
um 21.45 zum heute-journal im Interview
der Bundeskanzler schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
guten Abend heute morgen gab es erstmal
Nebel als der sich aufgelöst hatte
entwickelten sich einige Quellwolken es
gab auch dichtere Wolken zum einen hier
in Schleswig-Holstein an der
Nordseeküste wie auch in Süddeutschland
und da fiel dann regen das sind dann
genau die Regionen in denen wir auch
heute Nacht noch Regen erwarten
dazwischen lockern die Wolken auf es
bildet sich zum Teil neuer Nebel und es
kann wieder sehr kalt werden die
Temperaturen singen auf +3 bis -1 Grad
da droht also nicht nur ganz vereinzelt
Bodenfrost milder bleibt die Nacht ganz
im Süden und ganz im Norden bei acht bis
vier Grad die Höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen zwischen 11 Grad am Alpenrand und
18 Grad am Niederrhein und das wird ein
freundlicher Freitag sondern Wolken
wechseln sich ab und am sonnigsten ist
es wohl hier zwischen Berlin Brandenburg
und der Ostseeküste der Wind weht noch
recht schwach aus südwestlichen
Richtungen anna sieht sie im Süden aus
in Niederbayern kann es vor allen Dingen
am Vormittag noch einige Regenschauer
geben nachmittags man kann die Wolken
dann auch im Allgäu mehr und mehr auf
und dann kommt ein wirklich sehr
windiges und regnerisches Wochenende bei
Temperaturen von 10 bis 19 Grad zum Tag
der Deutschen Einheit am 3 Oktober am
Montag wird es dann von Südwesten
deutlich freundlicher guten Abend